I will talk to my friends, I will run my mobile, I will go to the wedding function,
I will have fun with my younger brother and sister and not possible at all.
The limited time you have, actually you have very limited time, very limited time, and there is still time.
Do something like this in life, that once in a lifetime, the whole of India is watching you leaving your work.
And I can tell you with a statement, that Khrushi,
at this time, watching four reels on mobile, playing a game, talking to friends,
fighting with people of no reason, I will go somewhere with all of them.
Think in your mind.
Imagine once, who is sitting in a small room today and watching this video on his mobile.
The one who is better than them in the house, where all the beauty will be,
where he can buy his mother, his father new clothes,
where he can sit in his father's car and earn money,
where he can send his mother a helper when he has to go to buy vegetables.
That's life too.
That life will be very beautiful.
When you can do something for your parents,
you will be feeding a lot of poor people,
you will be helping a lot of people,
you will be teaching a lot of poor children,
you will be opening the orphanage,
that is also a life.
You will be so happy in that life, so happy.
And I can tell you with a statement, that Khrushi,
watching 4 Reels on mobile at this time, playing a game,
talking to friends, fighting with people of no reason,
I will go somewhere with all of them.
I just want to ask you one thing,
what is this preparation for you?
This is your choice, this is your helplessness.
So the one who is helpless, do something else in life.
If your parents are forcing you to get ready,
it is possible that they will leave,
then I will not become a good doctor.
That is when you will be nothing,
the person who is not able to do anything,
the other person who can not do anything,
you will not do anything good,
you will not do anything good.
The one who has a choice, that is my question.
If anything is your choice,
why do you need motivation to do this?
You have chosen yourself,
if you want yourself,
why do you need motivation?
The movie of Avengers comes,
it is our choice to watch.
Or we say to our friends,
please motivate me,
that I should go for the movie of Avengers.
Please, please Pinky,
please tell me something like that,
Pinky, that I should be motivated
and watch the movie of Avengers.
Please Priya,
give me a little motivational lecture,
that I should watch the movie of Avengers.
No, let's go by ourselves.
Let's buy a ticket,
let's buy popcorn,
whenever I feel,
this is the question,
whether this is my helplessness
or this is my choice.
If it is your choice,
then it is clear,
that you have chosen yourself.
After finding it,
many children say,
oh no, it's wrong,
it's like this,
you will feel this every time.
You will go every night,
you will think once,
that I have caught this Ram,
now I will go this night,
you will go a little far,
you will get tired,
you will get bored,
because you leave something else.
You have seen your parents,
you have come from your father,
you will get power from your mother,
you will get power from your mother.
Get up in the morning,
go to the office every day,
come home in the evening,
talk to you a little,
eat, eat,
take care of all the things
in the house,
manage the house,
sleep,
go to the office in the morning,
with the boss in the office,
this, this, this,
work in the whole office,
struggle for you,
reach the office in the sun,
it is an office life easy,
what do you think,
it is so much work pressure,
come in the evening,
talk to you with love,
oh my child,
do it, do it,
what do you want,
take the child's mobile,
take the child's food,
what do you want,
take the child's shoes,
it's okay,
you will get bored,
be patient,
it's very bad,
it's very hard,
your father's work is also very hard,
he is doing it for you,
for all those students,
whose studies are in a bad state,
in a very bad state,
whose preparation is not at all,
whose preparation is in a very bad state,
but in the mind and in the heart,
seriously,
limited time you have,
actually,
you have very limited time,
very limited time,
and there is still time,
otherwise it will be an exam,
after that,
you will feel bad,
that it was time,
sir told us,
we will not go,
I mean, you have 10 to 12 hours per day,
now, what should be our plan in this,
the question is,
what is the plan,
sir, he understood that
there is less time,
we all realized that,
there is limited time,
we also understood that,
there will be a lot of children from us,
who will jump and go ahead,
this is also true,
I will not go,
so, the one who will watch this video,
someone else will go,
this is right,
that there are a lot of seats,
empty here,
which will fill,
there is a lot of empty space here,
there are a lot of empty boxes,
there is a lot of space here,
so, definitely,
a lot of children will jump and come,
if I will not come,
someone else will come,
what is the plan,
how should I do this,
how should I organize my day,
what should I do,
what is the plan,
sir, we make a little plan from here,
we make a plan from here,
I will not make false promises here,
so, this is how all the videos are on YouTube,
we will have to talk practically,
that how we believe our 10 to 12 hours per day,
so, the first thing I believe,
that we have to cover the full syllabus from here,
I believe that we have to cover the full syllabus,
we have to cover the complete syllabus from here,
now, look at the time,
it will be better than the full syllabus,
that I break the syllabus into two parts,
the first part will be,
that I should do those topics,
part one,
I should do those 21% topics,
I should do the most important topics,
I should take important concepts,
I should solve the most important problems,
from which I should become 80% questions,
now, the decision of the understanding will be the same,
if I think from chapter 1 to chapter 30,
I will do all the books,
then it is not possible,
first of all, what should I do,
the most important,
all my high-weighted people,
first of all, I should finish this,
my high-weighted chapters,
I should finish this first,
how will we finish the high-weighted chapters,
for this,
I tell you,
that in a day,
look at the lecture of 6R,
6R lecture,
I have so much time in a day,
it is 10 to 12 hours,
let's suppose,
that we are studying for 10 to 12 hours,
first of all,
we will look at the lecture of 6R,
you do not have any time,
that you look at the live lecture,
your time is wasted,
chat,
completely focused,
we have to look at 6 hours,
and this we have to do for next 60 days,
in these 60 days,
I should cover all this,
first of all,
80% boss labels,
where all the questions are,
where the maximum questions are,
6 hours have passed in the lecture,
now it is possible,
that someone has 6 hours,
someone has 8 hours,
the remaining time,
I assume,
after this,
someone has 6R,
someone has 4R,
and practically,
someone has 2R,
now,
the remaining time,
you have to do practice,
and revision,
I should cover this,
day 1 to day 60,
cover high-weighted chapters,
which are the most important chapters,
we will solve those 80% questions,
first of all,
sometimes,
we have done the class,
we have got the homework sheet,
we have got the DPP,
we don't have to do the questions,
in the morning,
6 o'clock has passed,
7 o'clock has passed,
8 o'clock has passed,
whatever is your time,
after 8 o'clock,
I have finished this,
after that,
PYQs,
you will have to make your own
mistake notebook,
son,
where is the mistake,
when you have to solve the questions,
this mistake notebook will be very useful,
we will practice PYQs well,
and we will revise our mistake notebook,
we will revise it,
remember me,
now,
you have 10 to 12 hours in a day,
I am thinking of 24 hours,
since I woke up,
it has been 10 to 12 hours,
I have done a lot of work,
I don't sleep,
I don't wake up,
I don't eat,
there are such things already,
if you think,
I will do 1,
I will do 2,
I will do 3,
I will do 4,
I will do 1,
I will do 2,
I will talk to friends,
I will do 3,
I will run my mobile,
I will do 4,
I will go to the wedding,
I will go to the functions,
I will do 5th,
I will have fun with my younger brother,
not possible at all,
it is still possible,
son, it is possible,
the world says,
spread as much as you can,
I did not listen to the world,
that is why,
I think I could do something,
I say,
there are shops in the market,
there are shops of all chadars,
we will buy all the chadars,
and spread a lot,
we will see our dreams bigger,
one day our dreams will be bigger than our dreams,
do something like this,
in life,
that once,
it happens that
India is watching you,
leaving your work,